speaking of covet persistent coveted
mismanager Republican Texas governor
Greg Abbott has tested positive for the
coronavirus he's reportedly isolating
and he is receiving a monoclonal
antibody treatment according to his
office now remember that this is the
same Greg Abbott who wanted to block
local officials from mandating masks who
wanted to open everything who was part
of the administration whose Lieutenant
Governor Dan Patrick said Grandma will
sacrifice herself for the economy that
was early in the pandemic back in 2020.
now you might be asking why was Abbott
even tested given that he is
asymptomatic because he's reportedly
been tested daily and he finally turned
up positive for the first time this week
they've also announced that everybody
Abbott has been in contact with has been
notified now I really wonder whether
that's true because that is a ton of
people look at these videos in the video
I'm playing for you now this is from the
last couple of days you see Greg Abbott
indoors he's uh the the one in the
wheelchair in the middle of the frame as
the camera pans to the right without a
mask in a room with maybe a hundred
people without masks hugging taking
pictures shaking hands that was Monday
night when he was presumably already uh
positive for the virus his positive test
was yesterday here's another video of
Abbott on Tuesday yesterday on stage at
a big Republican event singing maskless
we know that singing is a major spread
activity this isn't a big crowd the
entire crowd is actually singing check
this out
[Music]
[Applause]
rushes
[Music]
okay so that that's that's uh probably
enough sorry for subjecting you to that
there
um so there is Greg Abbott a presumably
coveted positive singing and then here
is Abbott in a very cozy close-up
meeting with a supporter of some kind of
fan of his we might say masculus indoor
greeting at one of these events so how
many people did the Republican Governor
give the virus to
before he tested positive himself now he
will probably be fine
um he has the best medical care money
can buy your money by the way I mean tax
money he's getting the antibody
treatment he's reportedly asymptomatic
and think about that for a second
vaccinated and no symptoms and he still
gets the expensive antibody treatment
these guys are truly horrible zoom out
and it's this dystopian big picture they
go around advocating for not taking
precautions uh they say don't close
anything grandparents willing to die
sacrifice themselves for the economy so
they take no precautions tons of people
in their state get sick and die then
they get an asymptomatic case and
immediately get the best Treatment
available even one that would never go
to an asymptomatic vaccinated person and
they at least what's thought to be a
good treatment and then they pretend
that that's proof that we don't really
need to worry about it look listen I got
the vaccine seen I didn't wear a mask I
did my thing I got the expensive
monoclonal antibodies and I came out
fine so we really don't need to worry
about it even though that's a treatment
almost none of us would get if we were
to become sick and he gets it all paid
for by our taxes some federal state Etc
understand that this is not a minor
point
he's fully vaccinated
he's asymptomatic he feels fine but he
gets the monoclonal antibody treatment
anyway now the other possibility and a
few people wrote to me saying you know
David maybe it's not that he's
asymptomatic and getting the antibody
treatment maybe it's that they're lying
that he's asymptomatic he's actually
really sick but they're going to give
him that treatment anyway I just don't
think so I mean unless he the video of
him around a ton of people is from
yesterday so unless he got like really
sick late yesterday and they already are
putting him on the antibodies I just
don't think so I think that he's just
getting the treatment because he's the
governor of Texas and by the way
you know just just as a little because
you hear from all these anti-vaxxers the
vaccines not yet fully approved by the
FDA sir neither is the monoclonal
antibody treatment it's approved under
this very same type of emergency use
authorization that the vaccines are so
tons of anti-vaxxers it's funny because
they say
That vaccine no no no that's not fully
approved by the FDA plus we have a great
treatment if I did get it and I did get
really sick we've got the monoclonal
antibodies that's the same type of
emergency use authorization neither is
fully approved by the FDA so absurd at
the macro level
ridiculous at the micro level
feeds misinformation and some of these
Governors seem determined to just keep
going going
until such time that everybody in their
state has coveted and the first guy that
comes to mind when I think of that is
Republican Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
let's talk about him a little bit next
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com Pacman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even auto fill the card number
with one click and the payment is taken
out of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like I said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com Pacman